I want to jump into this next story we
got this from timcast.com Twitter
announces plan to tackle misleading
narratives ahead of midterms vows to
throttle tweets deemed incorrect
exciting like they did not do with all
the Democrats who were screaming that
the election was stolen in 2016. they're
now basically telling us they are going
to decide what is true the last election
they did this what did they do they
suppressed the hunter Biden laptop
information they suppressed anything
that was that was basically bad for
Democrats and now they intend to do it
again
so I I don't know if there's any point
in reading and what they claim is going
to be done their Civics they're a really
good news site I think you maybe should
read it no no but the point is like why
who cares about what Twitter has to say
about why they're going to be censoring
and controlling the flow of information
I'd like to hear a little bit about it
what's the official statement here at
least the Civic Integrity policy covers
the most common types of harmful
misleading information about elections
and Civic events such as claims about
how to participate in Civic process like
how to vote misleading content intended
to intimidate or dissuade people from
participating in the election and
misleading claims intended to undermine
public confidence in an election
including false information about the
outcome of the election Twitter said in
the announcement harmful the thing about
all that is you're allowed to do all
that stuff that's free speech as long as
you're not inciting violence sort of not
not entirely I mean you're allowed to
tell people not to vote Yes but you're I
don't think you're allowed to defraud
people by like telling them the wrong
voting day oh right things like that
okay so I follow a great account
um his name is political math it's
polymath on Twitter yeah yeah I love him
and so he tweeted he retweeted the cdc's
guidance about
um the kids vaccine between six months
and five years old saying like
absolutely get you know these young
children vaccinated and polymath
retweeted it and said fire these people
this is unspeakable stupidity on the
part of the CDC that agency should be
burned to the ground which is opinion
yes first of all it's opinion and second
of all it's a call to violence well
that's their interpretation no they call
it misleading oh okay don't call it a
call to violence but
if you look at the numbers of people who
have had their young children vaccinated
for covid between six months and five
years of age I wrote about this for
Deseret like two weeks ago the numbers
aren't like three percent right now so
when I see a misleading tag on
polymath's opinion about the CDC
statement it makes me be like oh there
is something up there like it backfires
right yeah because I see that and I
think like why are they gatekeeping like
that but I think a lot of this is just
failed it's it's what's the right word
what's what's the politically correct
word of saying your brain doesn't work
the people at Twitter are really dumb
and there are people at Twitter that are
really evil and then you have the
government trying to get Twitter to
censor people which we've heard over and
over and over again now so what happens
is they're like hey let's Implement a
policy what happens there was there's
been several instances where people's
tweets have been flagged and the fact
check is totally unrelated and it's like
this really weird thing like huh there
have been several instances where
guidance has changed and they've been
like Hey we're revived the CDC is like
we're providing our guidance and then
Twitter Flags it as fake news here's
what the CDC says and then links to like
an article from the year before there
was a famous incident on Facebook where
this I think it was the cdc's own
website was labeled fake news
because these machines don't work they
don't know context they don't have
updated information and so if someone's
like I got breaking news the CDC says X
they'll delete you and say that was fake
news in your band because artificial
fact Checkers have not yet published the
information yeah so when they talk about
getting involved in the election at what
point I I you know you know I don't even
say I was going to say at what point do
we as a society do something about the
interference and manipulation of our
elections the problem is there's no
there's no mechanism for for solving
this and there's no uh there's no that
that's it there's no political process
for solving it it's just there Twitter
is this corrupt broken evil machine and
I don't care if the intention put into
was good what came out was evil and what
do you do antitrust the people who run
this this platform are all out of their
minds Elon doesn't even want it anymore
and he said he hopes that he doesn't
have to buy it there's no there's no
saving these broken social media
platforms it's like
you build a machine that runs wild and
starts destroying you and you don't know
what to what what to do to stop it well
you got to free the schematics so that
people someone will figure out how to
stop it that's why I advocate for
freeing the software code you can at
least make it better and more
interoperable I think that people aren't
going to be able to take Twitter's code
and then change Twitter they're gonna be
able to replicate it exactly more
problematic versions of the same Garden
or better and then the people at Twitter
will be like oh we could do that let's
change our better does not mean better
for society I know better could mean
generates more Revenue which means worse
because now it's more algorithmic
manipulation making people click and get
you know depends on who you ask better
could mean more manipulation of the
masses to get them to vote for who I
want them to vote for but I think better
uh you know I kind of think
what do you think allotropically I think
that's not the right word but I think
like you know the betterment of the
whole of uh the community like
no one I don't want less constriction on
who's controlling it but I guess I don't
know I'm not in the military the
military commander would tell you that's
the you want to do the opposite with it
probably that you want to control it
that's the only reason you're not in the
military yeah I don't want to control
people but I mean that's the military's
job uh but I think with the twit like I
think it's nice to believe that people
would want to Rally around common good
and the betterment of other people
that's honorable and that's moral in a
lot of ways but why would Twitter and I
don't know a ton about freeing the code
for sure but like why would freeing the
code motivate people who are already
well we'll ask a question okay so
Twitter has a history of wanting to
manipulate people and control the world
view I would freeing the code suddenly
change their mind why would they
suddenly if someone else made something
that was similar but more moral why
would they be like that's a good idea we
should do that too they could have done
that already but he chose not to the
issue is
Twitter is not driven by morality moral
platforms exist and they don't have
traction what works is addiction
machines Instagram knows this Facebook
knows this too who knows this YouTube
knows this Tic Tac knows this they know
that they can give you a dopamine hit by
making you feel good and they they have
this built into their machines so what
would happen there are tech companies
that offer a service to generate
addiction they'll say are you building
an app come to us and we will build an
addiction routine into your app for you
to make your own machines and stuff they
actually figure out when you pull it
down how long do you want how addictive
you know how long do you want to wait
until it refreshes how many times you
need to win how many dings are you gonna
get right but what would happen is if if
they freed the code that guy number two
would build set up his own identical
addiction machine identical to Twitter
and equally as addictive but on his
thing he gets to make his own terms of
service he'll say on mine you can talk
about the CDC say whatever you want all
these people on Twitter will will try
this one and then why would they
let me at least State my claim here so
you can argue you set your claim all the
time and the issue and Hannah Claire
asked me the question I want to answer
it so it then you you used to make it so
you can still see the people on Twitter
from the new site so you're not actually
leaving you're just expanding the
process and you're creating um a
Marketplace of the terms of service
essentially instead of a Marketplace of
who owns the code so how does that not
already exist with with truth social
with parlor with getter with gab they're
not in our minds they don't interoperate
with each other yet and and why would
they well bigger Network that that has
nothing to do with more diverse Network
the the issue is you cannot make a
morally better system A system that
improves like Twitter Facebook is more
addictive and manipulative and power
hungry so I there's there's no solution
maybe Anti-Trust but Twitter is not a a
monopoly technically so there are other
places is the fact though if for sure
exactly and so there's literally there
is no mechanism we have today other than
like all of the people of this country
agree it's bad so we we pass a law
saying ban Twitter so here's my question
prohibition so opening the freeing the
code so would this basically provide a
window because here's what I'm curious
about as a in as a Twitter user what
happened with Alex Berenson like can
someone explain that yeah he wanted to
be on Twitter no I mean like what he was
banned and now he's back yeah he filed a
lawsuit because he wanted to be back on
Twitter he didn't want to go on any
other platform he wanted to be on
Twitter so it was the lawsuit that got
him back on he had a lawyer on last week
he settled with Twitter okay they
settled and he got his account back
interesting so would freeing the code
basically do what Alex did and and open
the door okay oh yeah well you could so
Alex if you got banned off Twitter he
could go on the new version and still
see all the people on Twitter from his
new version and he wouldn't be banned
off the new version why would their
database be be granted to you why would
you get access to their database because
you have the API you'd have access that
would be I mean that would be the law
that would be what you would have I'll
tell you this right now it's the reason
why I don't like talking about this is
that it literally makes no sense I don't
think so because the other option is
breaking up the company like an
Anti-Trust and that doesn't work because
they still have the code they can start
a new one what I want to know is like
who is the person who decided
to ban Alex Berenson like what was the
what was the decision-making process
there it is likely the government
intervened we don't know for sure so
that's what I want to know though and
and we'd love it if Alex Berenson could
like you know tell everybody and that's
why people are really mad at him because
the story goes and you know I don't want
to put words in his mouth or the mouth
of his followers but what people are
saying on Twitter in response to him is
that he promised when he got to
Discovery he would expose what was going
on instead he settled with Twitter got
his account back and then said sorry oh
that's yucky so people are like you know
he said in the future there will be more
to to to talk about in terms of
government involvement and censorship
and things like that we heard from Naomi
wolf she said that the CDC was going
after specifically she was kicked off
right she's not yeah oh no and so
there's something oh your bracelet
daughter's bracelet so she was saying
that it's we see this before uh Judicial
Watch uncovered documents I believe it
was Judicial Watch that Democrats were
going to these big tech companies saying
ban these people so so it's it's very at
this point I would say we're at probable
cause or Beyond we have actual instances
of evidence where the government is
using third parties to violate People's
First Amendment rights but they're doing
it circuitously so this was the lawsuit
that was just filed by a whole bunch of
the healthcare people
are I I don't know a lot about it but it
was the um I think it was Jay out in San
Francisco
Stanford Stanford Dr J and I can't say
his last name B this is all new I'm so
glad when people don't know things that
I don't know I'm so spaced out right now
I'm sorry no so there there's a lawsuit
that was just filed and it's funny I
actually just did a radio hit about it
and the host did the worst thing in the
world and he's like tell me about this
I'm like I will not talk about it no
thank you you have to you have to do
that and so I kind of like I muddled
through it as best I could but there was
a lawsuit filed by a whole bunch of
healthcare people about the fact that
the CDC and the government worked in
conjunction with the social media
companies wow to silence them which is a
violation of the First Amendment yeah
the government does not have the right
to go to companies and say ban these
people don't let them speak
yeah now the issue is as always it's
cultural
cultural enforcement is more powerful
than law enforcement and cultural drives
are more powerful than any platform
could be you can spin up as many
platforms as you want from truth social
to gab to parlor together
etc
etc and people don't use them they don't
unify on them and why why didn't Alex
Berenson just go on Truth social and
talk to those people why didn't he just
go on gab and talk to those people he
wanted to be on Twitter so he sued to be
on Twitter he accepted being on Twitter
and then he didn't give the people what
they asked for because being on Twitter
was more important to him because people
are on Twitter yeah it's the people it's
not the platforms can I correct myself
now that I've Googled it because I I I'm
a little bit of a jerk
um the person who filed the lawsuit is
one of my friends and I didn't know that
oh cool oh my surprise I'm really sorry
Justin Hart uh he's a he's a data guy
he's a marketing digital strategist
um he filed a federal lawsuit against
Facebook and Twitter and Joe Biden and
the Surgeon General for violating his
first amendment rights to his free spe
Beach he claims that the federal
government colluded with social media
companies to monitor Flags to spend and
even delete social media posts that
they'd they claimed contained uh
misinformation he's being represented by
Liberty Justice Center
um I'm sorry Justin I didn't know that
you were doing that I will I will say
there have been many circumstances where
big Tech has been sued and I am
flabbergasted by the weak arguments made
in such strong cases
so uh there's just been a handful that I
don't want to call anybody out
specifically to impugn their honor but
there have been very very strong cases
where you're like wow look at the
details of this case clearly the
government said ban this person and then
when they file a lawsuit they don't
mention anything about like they don't
go they don't go after the government
they don't include them as part of the
lawsuit they don't even bring up the
strong elements of the case as arguments
they just say something like our
contract was breached and I'm like
what am I missing here because I've
talked to dozens of lawyers about
various issues and you know to put it
simply I'm not a lawyer I can't speak
for why these lawyers have made weak
cases that ended up losing or settling
or just not accomplishing what they want
to accomplish but then when you talk
when you when you listen to the lawyers
on their shows and you will you listen
to high profile people coming out and
explaining what went down
they make it sound like they had a much
better case than they presented I don't
understand why they didn't go for it I
just don't know or maybe they just
didn't know I don't know
inner workings of legal that you'll
never know I don't understand
why more news outlets haven't filed
lawsuits against newsguard for instance
they they like Breitbart has written
articles being like how dare you News
Guard and it's like why don't you sue
them why don't you sue them yes exactly
you I know
I'm asking you and we said this last
week so like I don't watch every video
no no I'm not saying I'm not saying you
do I'm saying yes exactly because
we probably are okay I've I've been in a
dispute with them already they've
violated their own standards they
violated their own correction policy
they've accused us of being
irresponsible while holding themselves
to a lower standard stating that we get
an 82 out of 100 I I say it's a
statement of fact that they've rated us
on the basis that they are giving a
factual analysis but they are not they
don't follow their own standards or
policies and the reason I take this so
seriously people need to understand this
News Guard is used by advertising
agencies and big Tech to reduce
visibility of your content so if you sit
so we're 82 out of 100 I mean we're one
of the one of the best but they
arbitrarily gave our website a ding even
though our standards are greater than
theirs right new USA Today fabricated 23
stories and they say that's fine
there's I I want to be careful here
because there's some behind the scenes
stuff related to Serious malfeasance but
I have already issued a demand to them
and it is very very likely we will be
filing a suit so and I will probably
seek crowdfunding to help other
organizations that have been defamed by
them falsely and smeared in violation of
their own standards and there's a few
things people need to know about the
elements of defamation actual malice did
they know what they published was false
when it comes to opinion statements this
is probably going to be their big
defense that when we call you
irresponsible it's an opinion we'll get
to that they've also issued several
false statements and refused to correct
them for instance on the the label for
our website they have they claimed they
mischaracterized a post that's false
they injected words into it that's very
different from this characterization
it's a false statement of their actions
defaming us they accused our content of
being fiction and they did not as per
their own policy which is their standard
admitted that they said we were wrong to
say Tim cast content is fictional they
did that instead just scrubbed it from
the article in violation of their own
policies so I'm I'm particularly pissed
off about this but um I'll put it this
way I've talked about Wikipedia
standards how they put their own byline
in it I have no standing to go after
Wikipedia you give me standing on any of
these platforms and the first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to go to the
full extent possible legally and so
there's been a long ongoing conversation
with newsguard for instance they first
tried to claim we were fake news because
we accurately reported the contents of
the hunter Biden laptop they tried
getting us to editorialize is our
content and I said here's two News Guard
certified sources confirming the laptop
emails are real and verified and their
response was you know what this is a
little bit murky so we're gonna we're
gonna ignore this issue for now no you
don't get to send me an email demanding
we editorialize our content and then do
and then you omit from your own article
that you had an error in your own
assessments so I wait when they
published it with six errors in right
off the bat I emailed immediately and
demanded retractions Corrections and
they have refused every step of the way
to correct News Guard fabricated a quote
from me that pissed me off you know when
it when it was accusing uh Tales from
the inverter world of being fiction I
said that is a false statement and they
changed it but never explained as per
their own policy what they did wrong
they called it a mischaracterization I
challenge that that is a false statement
of fact on their own part I don't know
how that'll work in court but I'm really
really pissed off about this their their
rating system is arbitrary they have
dinged us simply because we are an
independent media organization USA Today
fabricated 23 stories and they give them
a perfect score Media Matters gets like
an 80 out of 100 and they and they're a
conspiracy crackpot website so anyway
I'm I'm frustrated because I'm pissed
off at these institutions but I believe
we have serious standing and reason to
prove that they have come there's actual
malice in the in the insertion of words
into a quote knowing I did not say these
things and knowing I never implied them
I'll give you I'll give you exactly what
it is because they're trying to argue
when we put words in your quote we're
implying something we know you didn't
say it I told them if you require a
website to fact check every single quote
from every every politician that is near
impossible but if that's what you
require from this we will we will do
facts in all quotes moving forward they
inserted the words that are false
changing what I was saying what I was
saying was you have you have demanded of
us an impossible standard oh my God by
adding those words they knew they were
manipulating my quote that is mouse and
I want to see what they wrote when they
were talking to their editors and
lawyers as to why they decided to change
the context of what I said they did not
admit as per their own correction policy
they did that so I think they outright
defamed libel to me and won't and so you
have actual malice and then Reckless
disregard for the truth and that they
don't abide by their own standards so in
their fact checking process they they
three times incorrectly labeled my job
at three different organizations called
our content fake Fiction and Fantasy I'm
pissed off about that and they labeled
cast Castle mundane which is an opinion
statement as per their own standard must
be labeled if they're not going to abide
by their own standards I am going to sue
the ever living out of them and you know
what if in the end the suit is dismissed
I long for the day News Guard files in
their Federal response why they are
allowed to have zero standards for their
own for their own journalists why
they're allowed to fabricate quotes why
they're allowed to smear into Fame a
plether of Independent Media
organizations and why they give perfect
scores to outlets like CNN and New York
Times who publish fake crap all the time
anyway I'm pissed off about it you can
tell little bit I mean I think a lot of
it your question your initial question
how you got started and all this was why
isn't anyone suing and I think it's two
things I think the people don't care
enough you're very obviously not one of
those people but I think the other
problem is that and I think we saw it a
lot with kovid people
are much more content to go along
because they don't want to start things
and so even though they see things that
are objectively ridiculous like putting
a cloth mask on a two-year-old baby
people are afraid to speak up because
that everyone is a coward and so I think
that there is a lot of that we had uh
Tucker Maxon and he said power likes to
be hidden
I mean I was asking them because we
bring this up quite a bit like where are
all the powerful people to just come out
make powerful statements buy commercials
put up Billboards and challenge the
things we know they're privately
complaining about where are all the
Hollywood celebrities that privately
complain about this stuff but then don't
stand up there's a really great comic
where it shows a guy burning a woman at
the stake and he's he says I just want
to let you know I completely agree with
everything you said that's that's that's
modern mainstream Society unfortunately
so I I don't know man I imagine sooner
or later someone's gonna get pissed off
enough with me and they're gonna try and
do something we've already been swatted
nine times a little nervous about that
actually speaking of which well we have
we have armed security and things like
that I would say one of the other things
I think happens is that it's expensive
to to make your legal battles a priority
and I think there are other Independent
Media companies who are probably beating
treated I mean this is particularly uh
horrendous treatment of organization and
of course I I hesitate to comment on it
because I've been with Tim cast since
The Newsroom began I've been here for
like a year so this is a lot of my work
that's being scrutinized and
I am very glad that you're willing to do
something about it because I think we do
hold ourselves and all of our
journalists to an extremely high
standard that being said I do know there
are small organizations that would love
to go to court but have to make the
decision can we afford to do this
because it can be protracted especially
when you fight larger companies they can
drag it out I mean anyone who sued
Facebook for anything knows this
yeah I think though
I I imagine there's a community of
people who are willing to
stand up and be involved James O'Keefe
from Project Veritas they've they've
crowdfunded the fun the the the finance
is required to file a lawsuit and
they're going up against the New York
Times and regardless this is what people
need to understand too winning doesn't
mean having a judge bang a gavel and say
for the plaintiff winning means getting
these organizations to admit they're
liars and and their and and they publish
fake garbage
so all you know look I all I want is I I
told News Guard right off the bat How
Could You deem us irresponsible but have
a lower standard than us and they just
said too bad so sad go cry about it
something that effect we we we make our
judgment space on the fact that we're
looking for you to correct these
articles without us coming to you for
them and I said we've corrected
substantial articles without you coming
to us and telling us to correct them you
found five articles that you had
questions on only one of which had a
factual inaccuracy which we corrected
right away as prayer Corrections policy
it's arbitrary there is no objective
standard and right now newsguard is
falsely claiming that we publish
misleading information why because we
quoted the president
we quoted Donald Trump in a news story
and they said that that qualifies us for
publishing misleading content so when
USA Today or the New York Times quotes
Donald Trump are they not publishing
misleading content the argument is
Trump's quotes are misleading right
why is it only when we do it great I
want them to answer to a judge why it is
the New York Times can publish the exact
same thing as us in terms of the
reporting and the quotes and that's
responsible but for us it's not it's
because I think there may be a motive
that is more attuned to causing harm
intentional injury and monetary damages
to small small businesses that might
compete with the friends of these
organizations and their investors yeah
anybody who tries to create a new Media
Company anybody who tries to to report
news that falls outside of the official
Cathedral narrative for some reason has
a really rough go with it so I'll tell
you this
in The Newsroom as Hannah Claire can
attest to I've been extremely adamant
about abiding by every one of
newsguard's policies because I wanted to
see that if we went above and beyond it
at everything they deemed to be correct
would they would they honor that and
they did not because they are fake
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there